ever since I can remember African
elephants have filled me with a sense of
complete or they are the largest land
mammal alive today on planet Earth
weighing up to seven tonnes standing
three and a half metres tall at the
shoulder they can eat up to 400 kilos of
food in the day and they disperse vital
plant seeds across thousands of
kilometres during their 50 to 60 year
life span central to their compassionate
and complex society are the matriarchs
these female strong leaders nurture the
young and navigate their way through the
challenges of the African bush to find
food water and security their societies
are so complex were yet to still fully
tease apart how they communicate how
they verbalize to each other how their
dialects work and we don't really
understand yet how they navigate the
landscape remembering the safest places
to cross a river I'm pretty sure that
like me most of you in this room have a
similar positive emotional response to
these most magnificent of all animals
it's really hard not to have watched a
documentary learnt about their
intelligence or if you've been lucky to
see them for yourselves on safari in the
wild but I wonder how many of you have
been truly utterly terrified by them I
was lucky to be brought up in southern
Africa by two teacher parents who had
long holidays but very short budgets and
so we used to take our old ford cortina
estates and with my sister will pile in
the back take our tents and go camping
in the different game reserves in
southern Africa
it really was heaven for a young budding
zoologist like myself but I remember
even at that young age that I found the
tall electric fences blocking off the
game parks quite divisive sure they were
keeping elephants out of the communities
but they also kept communities out of
their wild spaces it really was quite a
challenge to me at that young age
it was only when I moved to Kenya at the
age of 14 when I got to connect to the
vast wild open spaces of East Africa and
it is here now that I feel truly
instinctively really at home I spent
many many happy years studying elephant
behavior in a tent in Samburu National
Reserve under the guy - if of professor
Fritz Vollrath and Iain douglas-hamilton
studying for my PhD and understanding
the complexities of elephant societies
but now in my role as head of a human
elephant coexistence program for save
the elephants we're seeing so much
change happening so fast that it's urged
a change in some of our research
programs no longer can we just sit and
understand elephant societies or study
just how to stop the ivory trade which
is horrific and still ongoing we're
having to change our resources more and
more to look at this rising problem of
human elephant conflict as people and
pachyderms compete for space and
resources it was only as recently as the
1970s that we used to have 1.2 million
elephants roaming across Africa today
were edging closer to only having
400,000 left and at the same time period
the human population has quadrupled and
the land has been fragmented at such a
pace that it's really hard to keep up
with too often these migrating elephants
end up stuck inside communities looking
for food and water but ending up
breaking open water tanks breaking pipes
and of course breaking into food stores
for food it's really a huge challenge
can you imagine the terror of an
elephant literally ripping the roof off
your mud hut in the middle of the night
and having to hold your children away as
the trunk reaches in looking for food in
the pitch dark these elephants also
trample and eat crops and this is
traditionally a roading away that
tolerance that people used to have for
elephants and sadly we're losing these
animals by the day and in some countries
by the hour - not only ivory poaching
but this rapid rise in human elephant
conflict as they compete for space
sources it's a massive challenge I mean
how do you keep seven-ton pachyderms
that often come in groups of ten or
twelve out of these very small rural
farms when you're dealing with people
who are living on the very edge of
poverty they don't have big budgets how
do you how do you resolve this issue
well one issue is you can just start to
build electric fences and this is
happening across Africa we're seeing
this more and more but they are dividing
up areas and blocking corridors and I'm
telling you these elephants don't think
much of it either particularly if
they're blocking a really special
waterhole where they need water or if
there's a very attractive female on the
other side it doesn't take long to knock
down one of these poles and as soon as
there's a gap in the fence they go back
talk to their mates and send me that all
through and now you have 12 elephants on
the community side of the fence and now
you're really in trouble people keep
trying to come up with new designs for
electric fences well these elephants
don't think much of those either
so rather than having these hardline
straight
electric really divisive migrator e
blocking fences there must be other ways
to look at this challenge I'm much more
interested in holistic and natural
methods to keep elephants and people
apart where necessary simply talking to
people talking to rural pastoralists in
northern Kenya who have so much
knowledge about the bush we discovered
this story that they had that elephants
would not feed on trees that had wild
beehives in them now this was an
interesting story as the elephants were
foraging on the tree they would break
branches and perhaps break open a wild
beehive and those bees would fly out of
their natural nests and sting the
elephants
now if the elephant's got stung perhaps
they would remember that this tree was
dangerous and they wouldn't come back to
that same site it seems impossible that
they could be stung through a thick
skinned elephant skin is around two
centimetres thick but it seems that they
sting them around the watery areas
around the eyes behind the ears in the
mouth up the trunk it's not you can
imagine they would remember that very
quickly and it's not really one sting
that they're scared of African bees have
a phenomenal ability when they sting in
one site they release a pheromone that
triggers the rest of the bees to come
and sting the same site so it's not one
bee sting that they're scared of it's
perhaps thousands of bee stings coming
to sting in the same area that they're
afraid of and of course a good matriarch
would always keep her young away from
such a threat young calves have much
thinner skins and it's potential that
they could be songs through their
thinner skins so for my PhD I had this
this unusual challenge of trying to work
out how African elephants and African
bees would interact when the theory was
that they wouldn't interact at all how
was I going to study this well what I
did was I took the sound of disturbed
African honeybees and I played it back
to elephants resting under trees through
a wireless speaker system so I could
understand how they would react as if
there were wild bees in the area and it
turns out that they react quite
dramatically to the sound of African
wild
here we are playing at the BB sounds
back to this amazing group of elephants
you can see the ears going up going out
they're turning their heads from side to
side one elephant is flicking her trunk
to try and smell there's another
elephant that kicks one of the calves on
the ground to tell it to get up as if
there is a threat and one elephant
triggers a retreat and soon the whole
family of elephants are running after
her across the savanna in a cloud of
dust
[Music]
now I've done this experiment many many
times and the elephant's almost always
flee not only do they run away but they
dust themselves as they're running as if
to knock bees out of the air and we
placed infrasonic microphones around the
elephants as we did these experiments
and it turns out they're communicating
to each other in infrasonic Rumbles to
warn each other of the threat of bees
and to stay away from the area so these
behavioral discoveries really helped us
understand how elephants would react
should they hear or see B sounds this
led me to invent a novel design for B
high fence which we are now building
around small one to two acre farms on
the most vulnerable frontline areas of
Africa where humans and elephants are
competing for space these B high fences
are very very simple we use 12 beehives
and 12 dummy hives to protect one acre
of farmland now a dummy hoy is simply a
piece of plywood which we cut into
squares paint yellow and hang in between
the hives we're basically tricking the
elephants into thinking there are more
beehives than there really are and of
course it literally halves the cost of
the fence so there's a hive and a dummy
hive and a beehive and our dummy hive
every 10 metres around the outside
boundary they're held up by posts with a
shade roof to protect the bees and
they're interconnected with a simple
piece of plain wire which goes all the
way around connecting the hives so if an
elephant tries to enter the farm he will
avoid the beehive at all cost but he
might try and push through between the
hive and the dummy hive causing all the
beehives to swing as the wire hits his
chest and as we know from our research
work this would call the as cause the
elephants to flee and run away and
hopefully remember not to come back to
that risky area the bees swarm out of
the hive and they really scare the
elephants away these be high fences
we're studying using things like camera
traps to help us understand how
elephants are responding to them at
nighttime which is when most of the crop
raiding occurs and we found in our study
farms that we're keeping up to 80% of
elephants outside of the boundaries of
these farms and the bees and the Beehive
fences are also pollinating the fields
so we're having a
reduction both an elephant croc raids
and a boost in yield through the
pollination services that the bees are
giving to the crops themselves the
strength of the beehive fences is really
important the colonies have to be very
strong so we're trying to help farmers
grow pollinator friendly crops to boost
their hives boost the strength of their
bees and of course produce the most
amazing honey this honey is so valuable
as an extra livelihood income for the
farmers it's a healthy alternative to
sugar and in our community it's a very
valuable present to give a mother-in-law
which makes it almost priceless
we now bottle up this honey and we've
called this wild beautiful honey
elephant friendly honey it is a fun name
that it also attracts attention to our
project and helps people understand what
we're trying to do to save elephants
we're working now with so many women in
over sixty human-elephant conflict sites
in nineteen countries in Africa and Asia
to build these be high fences working
very very closely with so many farmers
but particularly now with women farmers
helping them to live better in harmony
with elephants one of the things we're
trying to do is develop a toolbox of
options to live in better harmony with
these massive pachyderms one of those
issues is to try and get farmers and
women in particular to think different
about what they're planting inside their
farms as well so we're looking at
planting crops that elephants don't
particularly want to eat like chilies
ginger
Moringa sunflowers and of course the
bees and the beehive fences loves these
crops too because they have beautiful
flowers one of these plants is a spiky
plant called sisal you may know this
here as jute and this amazing plant can
be stripped down and turned into a
weaving product we're working with these
amazing women now who live daily with
the challenges of elephants to use this
plant to weave into baskets to provide
an alternative income for them we've
just started construction only three
weeks ago on a women's Enterprise Center
where we're going to be working with
these women not only as expert
beekeepers but as amazing basket weavers
they're going to be processing chili
oils sunflower oils making lip balms and
honey and we're somewhere on our way to
helping these participating farmers live
with better
generating projects that live and work
better with living with elephants so
whether it's matriarchs
or mothers or researchers like myself I
do see more women coming to the
forefront now to think differently and
more boldly about the challenges that we
face with more innovation and perhaps
with some more empathy towards each
other I do believe we can move from a
state of conflict with elephants to true
coexistence thank you
[Applause]
[Music]